jarring we begin this hour with a close
look at what could be a revolutionary
new medicine available starting today
the fda recently approved the
prescription eye drop called vuetti for
people with age-related blurry vision
first on cbs morning's national
correspondent jarika duncan spoke with
the woman who tried the medicine and
liked what she saw jerika good morning
good morning yes she did nate these eye
drops won't turn back the clock on aging
eyes but they could potentially replace
reading glasses for some of the 128
million americans who have trouble
seeing close up after age 40.
tony wright has the perfect view from
this western pennsylvania farm which she
shares with her husband and their four
children
when she's not checking on her chickens
hello
or cows yeah he's just a little baby she
works from home as an online retail
consultant i have readers everywhere i
have them in my car in the bathroom
in the kitchen it's the only way the 54
year old can see things clearly i was in
denial because to me that was a sign of
growing older you know needing to wear
glasses you can't put eye makeup on with
your readers on in 2019 her doctor told
her about eye drops with the potential
to correct her vision problems
temporarily basically i would put the
drops in my eyes in the morning one drop
in each eye what did you notice
instantly i would not need my readers as
much especially on the computer where i
would always need to have them on
wright was one of 750 participants in a
clinical trial to test the drug viewity
it's the first fda approved eye drop to
treat age-related blurry near vision
also known as presbyopia not only does
it improve your mirror and your
intermediate but it does not affect your
distance vision
dr george waring was principal
investigator for the trial he says the
drug takes effect in about 15 minutes
how do these eye drops work vueity
utilizes the eye's natural ability to
reduce its pupil size reducing the pupil
size expands the depth of field or the
depth of focus and that allows you to
focus at different ranges naturally one
drop in each eye provides sharper vision
for 6 to 10 hours a spokesperson for
viewity says the medicine will cost
about 80 dollars for a 30-day supply it
works best in people age 40 to 55 and
side effects in the three-month trial
included headaches and red eyes because
we don't know the long-term effects is
this something that you all will be
studying the people who take this
prescription this is something that we
anticipate will be well tolerated long
term but this will be evaluated and
studied in a formal capacity as for tony
wright and millions just like her it's
an easy backup solution with a clear
advantage how much of a life changer has
this been for you it's definitely a life
changer just a convenience to have that
option of putting the drops in and being
able to go
the prescription drops are for mild to
intermediate cases and are less
effective after the age of 65 as eyes do
age beauty is by no means a cure-all and
the maker does caution against using the
drops when driving at night or
performing activities in low light
conditions you may also have temporary
difficulty in adjusting focus between
objects near and far but it's definitely
convenient and i'm starting to have that
issue right now with seeing things you
know on the computer
yeah i kind of like having my not not
great vision up close you know because
you look in the mirror you get older you
don't want to see a full sharp vision
vision about it oh my gosh i don't know
yeah you do when you look like you you
do no yes you do so 40 to 55. they said
it works best from that age group 40
yeah 40 to 55 and it really is about
whether or not it's like intermediate
issues or is it a mild case because you
have people that don't start having
those issues until they're maybe in
their late 50s yeah it's about where
your eyes are at but definitely a great
option and i'm always nervous about
messing around with the eyes but what
you're what you just showed us is very
important we should point out you say
insurance doesn't cover it insurance
doesn't cover it as of now um as far as
we know because it's not something
that's considered needed you know it's a
benefit it's an option it's sort of you
know luxury not to have to worry about
so we're looking at 80 a month they were
estimating so it's almost a thousand
dollars a year i did my my eight times
12. yeah yeah you got that couch i got
it i didn't use the calculator
thank you eureka